it's national inclusion week and i'm all
for a bit of inclusion
if it includes everyone but increasingly
the men and women who have served in our
armed forces feel they're left out
there are stereotypes of ex-forces
personnel marching around the workplace
parking orders or struggling with ptsd
a lot of employees are skeptical that a
trooper can change his camo
for a suit and blend in according to
research although 71
of employers said they'd consider
employing veterans only 39
would take on someone with no industry
experience
but even if they don't have industry
experience men and women from the forces
have
other hugely valuable skills they're
professional
they're loyal organized and they've cut
their teeth under extreme pressure
don't tell me those wouldn't be skills
of use in civvy street
employees need to recognize the
potential in the veteran community
give them a chance in a new environment
to show what they can do
and then and only then could they truly
call themselves
an inclusive employer
[Music]
right maggie before i switch to you just
have a butcher's at what i was doing in
town
my name is lee mcfarland i'm the founder
and ceo of y2x
okay y2x ytx is a veteran four veteran
business
it was founded in 2017. and why is
inclusion such an important part of your
business strategy inclusion
of veterans into y2x is really important
these are veterans that have had
millions of paying spent on their
training
and they're under utilized in the uk now
did you want to say something before i
come back on this one
on your introduction are you good no i'm
fine you're good all right i'm fine so
sorry because i thought you might
have your say before you get angry no no
joke there's lots of stereotypes about
armed forces in portland but i want to
debunk that stereotype with a story if i
may
okay when i was 15 years old i was
surrounded in
south end by a bunch of combat 18
neo-nazi thugs who had machetes and
hammers
and this total and absolute stranger
stepped in and stood between me and
these neo-nazi thugs
and asked them to back off he said he's
only a child leave him alone
and they rewarded him by forcing me to
watch as they stabbed him
punctured his lung and beat him all over
his body and then he fell to the floor
and they continued to stamp on him and
bash him with clubs
the police arrived they ran away i never
saw this guy again because the
paramedics took him to hospital
and uh um and and because he was a
complete stranger i never saw him again
25 years later last week i put out a
public social media appeal to look for
this guy now you may well be aware that
muslim representation
in the armed forces and muslim
relationships with the armed forces has
been somewhat shaky
because of iraq afghanistan it's been
not as good as it should be
right so i was delighted to find out
after 25 years when i put this appeal
out loads of media got involved to try
and find this guy he contacted me
through my lbc page
and asked to see me now i'm calling in
matt because he wants to remain
anonymous
i went to see him and i met him about
four or five days ago
and i sat him down i gave him a hug i'd
been waiting to give him for 25 years
and i asked him why he did what he did
for me i.e stand in front
of neo-nazi thugs and knives who stabbed
him why did he do that for a total
stranger you know what he said to me
phil
no he said well i was in the army and it
was my duty
and he said it's just what you do and i
looked at him and i said no it's not
just what you do no one stands it was
about six or seven by the way and i was
on my own so he stood in front of six or
seven
armed thugs i said obviously he was
unarmed
i said no one just does that he says
well it's the kind of thing you do in it
it's just like
you see something wrong and you try and
stop it
and i was so so um proud
to learn that this man was a british
army soldier who saved my
life and by the way that man has gone on
and again i can't reveal too much at the
moment but he's gone on to find a job in
the private sector he's doing very well
for himself 25 years later
and i asked him i said you have a family
said i have a wife and i have a child i
said how's your daughter he said she's
about three or four if i remember
correctly
i said sir i promise you that your
daughter when she grows up will know
that your father
her father saved my life and he's a hero
so i just want to back up what you said
often we don't appreciate
those who serve their life humility man
shows through there he doesn't want an
absolute hero so
you know we're not necessarily as
veterans demanding respect or even sort
of like begging for
all people's charity we just want a fair
shot in the marketplace basically i mean
no one can talk we want our skills to
cross-pollinate you know we want
we want people to take us seriously and
they do in many ways keep me updated on
that that's the most phenomenal stuff
can i just ask you just change the tax
slightly yeah do you think the services
do enough
as personnel leave whether they leave
the army or the other i do say that
their reintegration
into society should start you join the
army you should start learning about
civilian street the day you join the
army
at present you don't you get you get a
rehabilitation package as you get out
it's not great it's done by a soldier
that's probably served 26 years never
been a civvy himself
it's wrong and i've identified it's
wrong trying to get that up to the
headshed
is an unbelievable feat you know what i
mean it just don't happen because i
don't listen to you all the time
but if i was to reshuffle something it
would be you know the resettlement
packages would be would start the day
well i'm trying to say before the others
come in it's not all the employers fault
it's yeah they're all the employees
the military have have have to look at
their policies of how they discard
blokes into civvy street but where i'd
i'd like to see the civilian industry
pick up on stuff is
is to recognize that a lot of this like
i said before and i lose as i said yeah
i left school with a cycle proficiency i
took that twice i got nothing else
until the day i joined the army i still
only had that cycle efficiency because
none of my skills crossed decked into
civvy street
and it was hideous you know people just
didn't appreciate that and i think if
people could be more
you know if this word truly is inclusive
they've got to embrace the guys and
girls if they get out the forces
and they've got to look at what they've
done how they've achieved it where
they've done it and even if they haven't
got
experience in a certain sector they've
got to be given that chance to prove
themselves because they are trainable
they've shown that they've been trained
they've been trained at the highest
level i might sound really naive but i'm
really surprised that it's seen as such
a disadvantage if i were an employer i
would really be interested in somebody
who's got that
you know capacity to stick with
something all the skills you learn the
discipline the drive
and it's weird because when you're young
if you're a cadet or you you know you do
something like that while you're in
school that scene is a huge boost to
your cv
so it's weird i think that you know for
me listening to what you're saying
i think it's probably bigger than
individual employers i think it sounds
like there's a whole cultural change
that needs to happen where
you know i knew we were talking earlier
about the comparison with america where
it's a completely different relationship
with america doing it really well and so
that's why you know i'm trying to work
very closely with the americans to see
what they're doing and bring it back
over here
and fire it because there's a whole
atmosphere and we've talked about other
things like homelessness
like um you know um medical care and
housing like there's so
the whole package of ways where we do
not treat military personnel fairly
and this feels like just another one of
them and i think it's actually a bigger
cultural issue of just not valuing these
people i'll give you an example of a
young lad
i'm not gonna say his name either but he
left he was in he was one of these
driving type regiments
and he had all his driving licenses all
the way there wasn't nothing he couldn't
drive
everything you name it you could drive
it you know big smalls whatever
motorbikes the whole the whole kit and
caboodle
when he got out he got out um he only
did a couple of years and he got out
when he was under 20.
uh so he got all his licenses but he was
under 20. when he went to get a job with
a haulage firm
they went well you might have all your
licenses but you haven't got any
experience of doing this on the other
and they turned them away and that that
was someone who i do know quite closely
you know and i i was just shocked by the
fact you know he's achieved so much he's
got all his licenses
he's gone out and because you haven't
done it as a civilian
he would you know phil what they're not
what um what's the
um impact as it were of perceived the
issue of
post-traumatic stress disorder when
you're taking on army personnel i mean
just
let's just flash back we've all watched
bodyguards
phil hold on can i just ask a question
which is we all watch bodyguard and
actually
lots of the main characters were ex-army
with ptsd
from the hero bodyguard to one of the
shooters who tried to take a pop at the
home secretary i don't know if he
watched it
so ptsd has been brought into the
foreground it's foregrounding
i kind of you must have already watched
so i mean
and the other question i have is so what
how important is that perception and two
what is the average
age of people leaving the army i mean if
they're in their 50s i sort of
understand why they don't
you know find work very quickly if
they're in their 20s it doesn't make any
sense
it's the ones that are in their 20s that
are suffering from the stigma
of the ones who've gone before them i
think in some respects now with the ptsd
it's an extremely
extremely huge problem that we have okay
however it's not with every soldier okay
but the problem that we've had is to
raise the awareness
we've had to sort like we've got to
paint everybody with the same brush
well from people who are too humble
about their achievements to the other
end of the spectrum
it's easy to get carried away sometimes
when you're boasting about just how much
you have achieved
to exaggerate slightly just to make a
point
when you're the president of the world's
most powerful country however
and the people you're addressing are
your fellow leaders at the united
nations
it might be wise to remember they're
more likely than most
to rumble you if you take it too far
in less than two years my administration
has accomplished more than
almost any administration in the history
of our country
america's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
for that reaction mr trump we think you
deserve the slap down
of the week what was he thinking though
it's all true
but he was kind of able to laugh at
himself well i i was surprised actually
that it was
almost anything maybe he's just starting
he's starting to row it back again he
didn't say
that's free so at that time he said he's
got his poles his poles are better than
abraham lincoln's
there weren't even polls during those
days
sadly that's what we've got time for
this week but don't forget you can join
in the debate by searching for the
pledge on facebook or twitter
thank you for watching
you